what moviegoers find scary differs
dramatically from person to person but
everyone can agree that some horror
movie tropes are totally played out from
zombies to creepy kids to haunted dolls
these are the horror movie staples that
should be laid to rest there are plenty
of terrifying movie monsters out there
but which one perfectly combines extreme
gore and mindless violence into one
flesh-eating package I'm thinking
zombies that's right however something
strange has happened to these undead
villains in the 21st century zombies
just aren't as scary as they used to be
zombies lost a good chunk of their bite
in the 2000s with films like zombie land
and Shaun of the Dead which deliberately
take all the gravitas out of the Walking
Dead zombies became downright funny and
were also portrayed as increasingly easy
to take out unlike other supernatural
creatures you don't need silver holy
water or wooden stakes to dispatch a
zombie as long as you've got a couple of
long-range weapons and you're smart
about how much noise you're making
you could probably live indefinitely in
the zombie apocalypse who knows you
might even have time to develop your
very own undead transportation system
really a lot of zombie movies these days
tend to be blood-soaked comedies or
action flicks rather than outright
horror films the creatures just amble
around while armed civilians pick them
off one by one or use them as visual
punchlines many of these movies are
seriously entertaining but they're not
even close to being frightening Night of
the Living Dead truly terrified
audiences when it came out in 1968
however more recent movies like Pride
and Prejudice and Zombies and little
monsters probably won't make you scream
but they might make you laugh or even
cheer
creepy kids are an understandably
popular horror trope children are
supposed to exemplify innocence so to
see that purity tainted by say a demon
is definitely disturbing from Damien in
the omen to the twins in the shining
kids have been extraordinary tools of
terror for decades but this storytelling
device lost a whole lot of power in
recent years the thing about creepy kids
is that well they're still kids they
have the potential to be seriously scary
if a scene is done right but if it's not
things can get silly really fast
also some modern horror films seem to
assume the audience will be frightened
of any child doing commonplace things as
long as those moments are punctuated by
a loud music cue then there's the
tendency of filmmakers to randomly wedge
a strange kid into a movie just to add
an extra bit of atmosphere or whatever
this is
discovering that a young character is
capable of supernatural mayhem used to
be a novelty these days it's so overdone
that it would be more shocking to see a
normal kid who is under the influence of
sugar rather than an ancient curse plus
even in classic horror films it just
feels wrong to root against children who
have gone to the dark side especially
when their adversaries are so much
bigger than they are films like
Rosemary's Baby terrified the world with
visions of about Satanists these days
however if you hear someone as a
Satanist
you might just laugh it off most
people's experiences with Satanists
involve heavy metal bands with lots of
makeup and awesome videos fans of these
bands may like the aesthetic of inverted
crosses and pentagrams but no one really
expects them to sacrifice goats let
alone people the Church of Satan's
website makes it clear that the members
are more interested in individual
freedom than literal devil worship
additionally documentaries like hail
Satan have revealed that real-world
Satanists aren't very scary and
open-mindedness and free expression all
of this means one thing for movies
Satanists just aren't that ominous
anymore no one's worried about them
roaming around their neighborhood and
robes looking for recruits there are a
lot of scary things in the real world
but generally speaking devil worshipers
aren't at the top of this list the Blair
Witch Project revolutionized horror
films not only is it genuinely
suspenseful in frightening it had a
totally unique marketing campaign
through the use of missing-person
leaflets and online message boards the
Blair Witch Project initially managed to
convince thousands of people that the
film was totally real and composed of
actual footage even today when everyone
knows the truth the raw found footage
nature of the film manages to impress
however the success of the movie along
with its rock bottom production costs
led to an overabundance of found footage
films and of course the quality and
impact of this sub-genre slowly
dissipated over time Plus no matter how
hard these movies try to convince
viewers that what they're seeing is
totally real audiences have become a
whole lot savvy ER all it takes is a
quick google search to show that a film
is not in fact based on a true story
those days are long gone the other issue
is that found-footage movies started to
feel a bit repetitive and loaded with
cliches like night vision jump-scare
that's not the safe found footage films
can't be great but filmmakers need to
find a unique angle on them much like
the Blair Witch Project did all those
years ago Chucky was far from the first
evil doll in cinema but he quickly
became the most popular since child's
play was released in 1988 haunted dolls
have cropped up in countless horror
movies including a never-ending string
of Chucky films whether it's Annabel and
the conjuring or Billy the puppet in the
Saw franchise there's something
unsettling about seeing a doll a puppet
or any child's toy used for nefarious
purposes however despite the
surprisingly high number of movies that
incorporate an evil doll you're more
likely to chuckle from their antics than
screamin horror at the end of the day
it's just hard to be afraid of something
you could toss in a toy box
sure the dolls usually have supernatural
abilities but a lot of movies don't
explore this very thoroughly featuring a
demonic doll in a film is just a fun
excuse to have a series of sight gags of
them attacking humans with their tiny
limbs sure it would be a shock to see a
Cabbage Patch Kid hopping towards you
with the power to land a murderous gleam
in its eye but it's probably not going
to give you any nightmares at the other
end of the spectrum there's the Haunted
doll that basically just sits there and
occasionally moves its eyes again at
some point this was probably terrifying
but now it just seems like the cheapest
possible way to make a horror movie
still the fact remains that studios are
constantly pumping out new movies with
cursed dolls and puppets so there's
clearly an audience for these films and
somebody is making plenty of money from
them now
who's the dummy check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about horror films are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]